to be
thank you for coming I wanted to start
by explaining why it is I had the
pleasure of interviewing Michael
seething and the I would direct your
attention to the dust jacket of your
book the back and there is a blurb here
that reads I read Michael Lewis for the
same reason I watched Tiger Woods I'll
never play like that but it's good to be
reminded every now and again about what
genius
looks like Malcolm Gladwell and my my
question is who's more shameless me for
writing that or you for putting it on
your book
I just stopped them from putting it in
an ad because they're wearing it out it
was a it was kind of you say it and we
both know it's not completely true but
if there is a there is a place for
hyperbole and I believe it's the back
jacket of book
I I have a theory I'm a grand unified
Michael Lewis theory and I thought that
we would start there I haven't heard it
I'd love to hear it yeah and I'm going
to um this is going to be I would like
to see whether you whether you get the
theory so I'm going to give you an
opportunity to answer you'll see the
theory the preamble to the theory is
that you are principally a moralist in
fact I believe you are America's leading
nonfiction moralist you mean by that
well you are someone who explores more
deeply moral themes and is proof I would
like to point out that in five of your
best-selling five of your best-selling
books are essentially biblical
allegories starting with I want to see
if you can guess the biblical allegory
how good is your you know it's very
funny you're saying this I mean I have I
did think of this one as an allegory but
it wasn't the Bible oh there's a pile of
tireless logistical just you get it out
there let's get out there get a large
poker star is what biblical story
[Laughter]
it's Daniel in the lion's den you're
Daniel right you descend into the line
then where you are beset by large beasts
who you hold a bag right duh okay
Moneyball Moneyball is the easy one
Moneyball is David and Goliath course
there are a lot of them are David well
no no that's not true yes The Blind Side
is the Good Samaritan right quite
literally a good American very true by
the side of the road
I mean it's the same story right big
short Noah's Ark right it was only one
of each kind in my story well know it
what do these guys do these traders do
they take refuge against the coming
storm by building themselves what an arc
a financial arc perfect okay so what
flash boys is it's the most perfect
biblical allegory of all which one is it
do you know how I do
it's Jesus and the money changers in the
temple room my father's house is the
place of Prayer but you have turned it
into a den of thieves
jesus said flash boys how is it
I was looking I got the book and I was
like where is the biblical epigraph from
second map from Matthew like for Matthew
1 whatever it is 24 couldn't find it
it's like you know what I want to know
is why I don't feel better understood
than I felt two minutes but but it's oh
it's okay I got the the you just you're
not disputing that there is a deeply
moral Center to all of your books
there's certainly in this case it is
more moralistic I think than many of the
things I've written but I think at all I
I think they're almost probably gesture
it's probably hard to write without
thinking without filtering it through
some sort of moral sensibility I it's on
the surface more in this book because
it's on the surface with the characters
and a lot of my characters don't feel
that way about the world around them in
this case you have you have a Canadian
such as yourself who comes who walks
into the American finance and what he
finds eventually appalls him because
he's Canadian and it's a that he is so
clearly not just appalled but we have so
it's such a clear sense of right and
wrong and what's going on is wrong he's
gonna fix it is a little different for
me it is all it's hard to make swing on
the page then some ambiguity that felt
that many of my characters had a lot of
moral ambiguity about them he has less
than anyone I've ever written but cube
but that I will I'll grant that but I
you you surely aren't saying may I find
that same I just explained I find that
same moral centeredness in think of the
earth think of all of your character
think of your great characters in those
five books well they're all in some way
in opposition to the world around yes
absolutely true and they they all have a
moral position on the world around them
what really to what is Billy being moral
position here's what I was going to
going to get to that in a moment but
he has a moral position and that is that
the the billet the money money ball is
an argument about privilege right at one
level the book to me was a book about
privilege I think of it as a book about
about value and about about how I think
about it is a book about how how
difficult how much difficulty markets
have placing value on human beings but
Billy Beane didn't think of it that way
Billy Beane could have given a rat's ass
about things like that I mean he thought
of it as a book about war his war
against the world around him but it was
it wasn't the more it wasn't thinking
really right wrong in a moral in a moral
way he was thinking he was thinking
right wrong like my math is better than
your bad I know but you don't think
there's a moral dimension to someone who
says we have fundamentally misunderstood
people's true value in the world I say
that yes yeah he doesn't oh we have it
here right the book yeah that's true
so no I you know I think it is true that
but I don't think this makes the unusual
as a writer no no I know it is true that
what I mean what causes you to pick up a
just sit at your machine and type words
out in the first place it's some sense
of like something's wrong or something
the world miss perceives something and
you have a sense of a view of events
that feels at least to you perhaps
erroneously fresh different and all that
view is driven by some moral concern I
think that's fair I'm not sure on more
this way than other people
I do you think I am oh it's it's heavily
really but I'm fully I want to win it
but I want to point out to go back to
your characters again I think there's I
think that if you list them Leanne chili
Steve Eisenman and Michael burry and in
Big Short Billy Beane Brad whatever his
named last name how do you pronounce it
snaps ooh Elmo Custer Yama in this book
even Lori Taylor
they all have there's something there's
a common thread that runs through them
don't you think
and I said before is true they're all in
opposition's the world around them every
one of those people but they aren't I
mean look everybody's got a moral
position even by default but I mean
let's take a character like Michael
Murray in the big short he's someone who
goes into finance after he abandons
medicine because he realizes he said I
care about people but not really and and
it's so indifferent to his fellow human
beings that then he takes refuge in
numbers now I guess that's a moral
position but it isn't it isn't I think
most real think of as a moralistic
character yeah but the point if I
thought when I read that that what was
so moving about I found Michael Murray
to be very moving me too
yeah I kind of moving because you did so
but what is true can I interrupt you for
that
all right this time trying to find some
truth in what you just said and I'm
doing my best
my a my wheels defining I mean the the
there is some fruit if it's true that I
have no interest in writing a book
unless I unless I feel something at the
bottom of all of them is emotion it's
absolutely true
so I write about often very dry things
baseball statistics subprime mortgage
crisis high frequency trading who cares
really and if you had told me if all I
needed was that the stock market was
rigged and here's how it written it's
rigged and Michael you can go explain to
the world how arrogant no one else knows
I I'm sure we've had an interest I don't
care that much the stock market is
rigged I'm going to care a little bit
but I don't care enough to sit down and
write about it what I cared about what I
care about is that this character walks
on walks into this world discovers it's
rigged and how the haze went with once
he has the understanding the chore the
moral choices he makes no question about
it and my own that engages my emotions I
that's what caused me to care of
the story so I have to I have to feel
something yeah and yeah and it is true I
would also say it's true that what I
feel is quixotic sometimes I was sitting
there watching I realized this when I
had my seven-year-old on my lap and I
was watching the 60 minutes show that
about the story two Sundays ago and I
realized I was crying and tears coursing
now if I was kind of embarrassed because
it was like just computers and numbers
and all but I was crying because I could
see the the character of the mane of the
of the guy I wrote about Brad Katsuyama
on the screen displayed so clearly and I
found that character moving so it is
being moved by things that causes me to
put any effort into this were you more
moved by his character than some of
those previous from some of your
previous heroes I find all of them kind
of moving I mean I heard in he was yeah
I like brave people and a lot of my
characters are brave he is he is he is I
will say this what he has done is
peculiarly brave because he's brought on
the wrath of the gods I mean he really
has he's gone to war with his own
industry in a way in a way Billy Beane
didn't even do until the book came out I
mean the ability is forced into that
position by the book Brad cause I'm a
went into war with the industry all by
himself so I found and I find him as a
character because he isn't by nature a
troublemaker not by nature someone who
goes out of his way to antagonize
systems I find him
I find that movie that he was forced by
circumstances to make choices that were
really almost unnatural to him to to
step outside of a system in which he was
quite comfortable personally to in
response to this immoral reaction he had
so he's forced almost forced into the
role and that once forced in the role he
Britt behaved so bravely so you so they
act Li what I had in mind when I
finished this book I thought to my I
just strange feeling that I read this
book I just wrote and what is this
reminding me of and I could cook me
while I put my finger on but here you
had this character Brad katsuyama who
had unleashed who had triggered was
sitting in the middle of this Great War
and the war was between people's people
with money to invest in the people who
were mishandling the money the middlemen
and the investors a war that that none
of them really wanted in some way but
now is happening he was in the middle
and he's short very short and he's in
some way a reluctant of a middle man in
this little rut reluctant participant I
thought oh my god I've just written Lord
of the Rings he spread out and I can and
I think I think of him as Frodo he's got
in a Frodo like way he's got a Frodo
like situation and I find his bravery
like Frodo's bravery what does it say
about the dunes between you and me that
I'm immediately drawn to the story of
the most dramatic story in the New
Testament and you think of Lord of the
Rings you were raised with a religion no
I
I clearly I have much grandeur
aspirations for your imagination than
you do why why is the holding of any
children driven sure I think the
motoring is pretty terrific actually
doesn't reread very well but I read it
the first time I thought it was pretty
terrific so I think of anyway so this
case so what all these people have in
common all these feel I'm in common
they're troublemakers in their
environment they're disruptive in some
way or other they have problems with
their environment all of which is really
useful in describing the environment the
carrot they're all characters in
situations well beyond that what is it
about you that is drawn to that specific
profile you know it's funny Malcolm I've
done this once before a long time ago
you won't remember because there were
six people in a Barnes & Noble in New
York when the blindside came out the
blindside came out and you were
perplexed
that all of my books seemed to be the
work of kind of basically someone who
has has radical hostility towards the
world around him and you couldn't
understand that I was I had rich parents
I was raised by the people with you and
your family your blog where this I just
and then I started says what you think
you said what is it was a where does
this hidden neurosis come from it's
basically your question and and I don't
know if I answered you properly at the
time but I if I had to put I don't know
if there's a good answer is probably
just based partly hat in some way I'm
wired you know I don't look I don't look
the way I'm wired but I do think that it
helps me as a writer that I grew up in a
world that I loved I grew up in New
Orleans that was a war and it was the
world it was outside in many ways
American culture and America it was
American culture was clearly hostile to
it in the Senate it was it was not going
to survive American culture and a lot of
things I valued in that world were
crumbling before my eyes
so I could see that my father's way of
life was unsustainable for example I
think that probably helped it what do
you mean by that I mean we what kind of
what was unsustainable about your
friends well it was unsustainable not to
care very much what you did for a living
or get your status from that success
from from your achievements in the world
as opposed to just your personal
relationships from from your family it
was not a success culture it really
people were largely indifferent to what
other people did to make a living and
much more focused on family
relationships and there was a kind of an
ironic twist - or not ironic strain in
life I kind of detachment musing a gift
for creating the culture had a gift for
creating wonderful moments
it wasn't yeah it was a naturalness
about it I just felt that it was a work
but it was it was not a successful
place it was a failed place in many ways
and you could see that a kid could see
that and you could see that you know you
could see that even the things you the
things you loved were not sustainable
right so I think so main to question
which makes you question success when
something you feel is very successful at
a very deep emotional level is by the
standards of the world of failure I
think that it's probably that really has
something to do with how I approach
subjects but I don't know how much I
don't know how much I mean the answer
the question maybe I'm just actually
basically lazy and that it's much easier
to write a story about a disruptive
person in an environment than it is to
say the kind of thing you do where you
actually have to you know think through
the idea very clearly from beginning to
end as opposed to use a character to get
you to walk you from beginning to end I
mean I we've had this conversation
before I'd maintain believe me do what I
do is harder but I don't way harder yeah
I think so to tie these two things
together might the Phantom the Lewis
family motto I kid you not when I was
growing up my father setting on the
conic on the coat of arms passed down
from generation to generation was this
do as little as possible and that
unwillingly all right there's more for
for it is better to receive a slight
reprimand than to perform an arduous
task and
and I thought that was serious yeah I
thought that made total sense to me and
so when am i writing life there is is
influenced by that kind of approach to I
mean I don't look for trouble or hard
things to do I look for I look for
things I can I can do without too much
trouble and I think you understand it
you're making no sense whatsoever right
now this is why you are invisible in
insanely prolific you have to come it's
not hard once I thought what that does
not make me feel better
nobody but once I find a story that
engages me and a character in a
situation engages me it's very easy I
mean I have to spend time with them
which just other people might be onerous
but and I have to kind of learn some
things but if I if it's if if the
situation the characters write the rest
often just kind of takes care of itself
and so maybe it's just for me maybe
given my proclivities maybe it's just
like what I am doing as a writer is
finding the path of least resistance
and that's we give you books with the
hardest to write probably the new new
thing and it's a good way to judge them
you know I think back home I think of
them almost like olimpic dive you have
to do that you have to have the degree
of difficulty as well as the execution
and the degree of definitely was hi
there because I had a character I knew
the reader wasn't going to see the whole
point of the character is using company
incredibly uncomfortable to be with that
he's in credit he doesn't the minute you
get settled he unsettles so he never
gives you a place to rest and it's the
culture of Silicon Valley embodies in
the person and that's very hard to make
- it's very hard for that he doesn't
form attachments very hard for the
reader to form an attachment with him
and so how that was I think probably the
harvest this one and the big short had
these technical details that were
difficult to kind of bring across a bit
it's heart basically impossible to
describe a collateralized debt
obligation I mean nobody no matter what
you do no matter what you do the best
you hope for in terms of some of this in
here is it you fool people into thinking
they understand it and so when they put
the book down this I pop that and they
go tell people they understood it but
they don't really understand it and so
you have to you have to give up artfully
with some things so that was true in
this case - there some places where I
just I get I just hope the reader felt
they didn't want to know anymore
but the but they're all I mean I find a
hard part of these things is structure
it's fine like what is the way to tell a
story once you find the way in tell
story it just tends to kind of almost
write itself and the highway which was
the easiest lowest to be a physical
lives poker because it was just about me
I was so vastly amused by myself - and
never in ever I mean this I'm told this
is true cat my wife Tabitha tells me
that I saw I write with headphones on
listening music and listen to say I was
also the same song over and over and
over on a loop just cuz it shuts out
everything else I wrote an entire
chapter of this book to the let it go
for us the something in frozen just over
over I felt like everything it was
really the same person and I walked the
world and I hear that song I just go
start to write because I get so used to
it but but but liars coke I'm told she
tells me that when I'm sitting there
with my headphones I'm cackling with I'm
at my own laugh at my own jokes and I
and with the lawyer spoke I'd never
written a book I had a bit written very
few magazine pieces even I know since
they would be actually a critical
reaction to this except we loved it and
so I didn't occur to me to have that
fears anxieties in here it was just easy
do you have any fears or in fact course
what are they
well I think I see I mean maybe not as
much as some but I hear the disapproval
of others and the do you know it's not
nice to get bad reviews beyond that I
mean in my literary life we have a lot
of time you could want to think about no
I think I think how could you come up
with something and not really not oh you
know probably not probably not I don't
feel so they'll let you have like I
think you must be this way to their
layers of insecurity underneath layer
and layers of confidence at the bottom
is confidence I know at bottom I'm not
really that worried about anything when
I write I don't I don't worry it's going
to be bad really
I think if I work hard enough that it's
going to be fine but usually it comes
very easily because I don't even get
that far
so I don't it's problematic right
because I'm supposed to writers are
supposed to be tortured and miserable
yeah and poor and I'm none of those I'm
very happy
more or less well-adjusted plenty rich
yeah and and and you know I just met
that peace for the world around me more
or less so I'm sorry I can't give you
what you need here I'm not requiring you
know I find this deeply refreshing
Our Mutual Friend another Michael told
me the key to understanding view is that
the commencement address you gave at
Princeton several years ago which I read
this afternoon
two years ago yam years ago sure about
this afternoon from the pulpit in the
church it was the first time I'd ever
been in the church much less the pulpit
but yeah and despite them can you
describe a little bit what that
commencement address was about and then
do you agree that there is something but
did you do you agree that it encapsulate
something real about the way you see the
world yes central so so these you have
problem minister dress the
undergraduates and not bore them and it
was kind of actually kind of funny I the
Princeton is such a small world I got up
I realized that this address I gave it
had been given since 1798 and every
class gets it so I had to have gotten it
when I was graduating from Princeton and
I don't even remember they even the
event much less the speaker and what he
said and so I started by saying that
that you know I must have sat there in
these pews and listed to some old guy
tell you something and I don't even
remember even being here so you won't
remember this and it turns out the guy
who gave the speech when I was uh
when I was a senior within the audience
because he had a grandchild graduating
from Princeton and I got him this nice
note from the lady two days later saying
Charlie was there my husband Charlie
wasn't there and he thought was really
very funny but you didn't remember what
he said
would you like to come to dinner so
they've actually become friends but as
of the theme of the speeches of the role
of luck in life accident life and and
that the people in the audience probably
even more so than when I was graduating
from Princeton think of themselves as
deserving of everything that comes with
them because they've passed through this
ruthless meritocratic filter they've
gotten the right board scores had gotten
the right grades everybody tells them
they're there because they because they
deserve to be there and so on somewhere
I know I was under no illusion that I
knew that I was there because my father
got the Preston and so I didn't think
I'd actually even deserved to be there I
thought was a privilege to be there but
because they were programmed the way
their program now I thought it was
important to tell them how much luck was
involved in them being there and how
much luck would be involving them
afterwards and that it wasn't just
enough to appreciate their luck that
they Oded debt to the unlucky and it was
a way what I was doing is smuggling into
Princeton back into Princeton
the idea of noblesse oblige which is an
ID I grew up with which is you know it's
one of those ways that to redress the
inequality in the societies for the
people who were the elites to think a
little bit about their responsibility of
the people who are not rather than just
coast on the fact they're early
part of the outrage of the story of this
book is elites are doing the opposite
leads are are instead of taking the kind
of responsibility for the rest of the
society or scanning it but
it's good Moni it's good to get to know
the audience isn't it kind of know which
way they're going to drift so I think
we're drifting left in here but the the
the the so when the point and it was
true that this theme tied into some of
my books money and ice commissioned the
Moneyball yeah was I mean part of
Moneyball is the A's the Oakland A's
figuring out how much luck there is in a
baseball career and trying to strip out
the luck to get to the true value of the
player but how hard that is to do so
that I was just trying I was trying to
bring that across to them and I'm sure
they forgotten already
I mean their parents may not about yeah
but it's do you think that idea I've
been aside from Moneyball has that idea
surfaced in because it is you need to go
back to my argument about moral themes
in your work there is a constant
engagement with this idea of privilege
about institutions that have become
corrupted with this isn't something new
columnist I guess when you put it that
way that's true you mentioned the books
are about them so Moneyball when you
think about but the privilege is the
privilege of a court it's the club of
the base of the old baseball scouts but
wasn't that it's about Moneyball is also
about the arrogance of the which the the
way arrogance has blinded the wealthier
clubs that's the other half of the
puzzle in that writer about how the that
that the New York Yankees of the world
have been misled by their riches what
smarm
what's more moral than that argument or
we're going to spend this whole
conversation you proving the point we
made in the beginning no no I don't want
to so I don't have to Lavery what if I
just want to analyze Kate I love bomb
you and I cave and I say okay you're
absolutely right I'm a myth it's not
about me making some you know ridiculous
argument God knows I do that enough this
is but I mean it ice but on the number
to leave it when we years ago when we
had our sing on stage for blindside
the other thing I said then I still
believe was that that to me blindside I
thought that the book was miss titled
remember that that you titled it you
made it sound like it was a book about
football and it wasn't a book about
football it was a book about charity
right about to book about Leanne Tilly
the book is I think the book is about
all the forces that affect the value of
this child of the center yeah and and
and how the outcomes in this child life
is life or so serendipitous that's what
it is it's a book that's the football
feeds into the it all comes back that's
the question is structure what's this
book about question is is why how does
this boy go from being the least value
to human being on the planet
a homeless illiterate kid eating out
garbage can on the streets of Memphis to
four years later being you know among
the most highly prized 18 year olds on
the planet what are the forces involved
in one of those forces is things that
have happened in the in football
strategy to elevate the value of what do
you so peculiarly you do so peculiarly
well and in other those forces as a
mother if he didn't then all of a sudden
he had so it all it all fit together
from he but you're right it wasn't just
about obviously wasn't just about yeah
well I say that by the way that's the
only I think that book is perfect
there's not a single word out of place
and I mean I love all your books but
that is to me of the mass as it will be
read fifty years now like am I really
good with it it was hardly read at the
time I miss my truth is well yes you
find when you write a book about
football that people who like football
don't like to read
this is my anyway we will yell then it
shouldn't that was my that was my
frustration I worried that people were
thinking was a football book when I felt
that and a few people who do read who
like football they really really don't
want a chick flick in the middle of
their football yeah so I felt I liked
shoving those two unlike things together
but but it did miss its market and the
movie the movie solved that problem but
if the movie hadn't made it would be my
least read book yeah yeah I liked it
though I was I'm with you I felt very
good at the enemy let's talk about this
one I don't know how much I don't have a
watch know how much time we have um
let's get to the book at least a little
bit tell me to talk a little bit about
the the origins of this I'm guessing
that this girl out of the PC you wrote
for Vanity Fair on the Russian
high-speed trading yes yeah quick
two-minute summary of how this came
about the the Russian computer
programmer caught my eye and this is in
2009 a high-frequency trading program in
his early thirties a Russian kid left
goldman sachs to work for a
high-frequency trading firm and mailed
himself some code and a couple of days
later the FBI arrested you who arrested
him and i follow this in the newspapers
a year or so later he sentenced to seven
years in jail and and and so the first
thing i wondered was why on the back end
of the financial crisis the goldman had
so much to do it was the only person who
went to jail the person goldman sachs
wanted to go jail
i mean it was the only goldman employee
with jail when goldman wanted to jail
but the thing that really caught my eye
was that when they arrested him the
prosecutor said that this code that he
had to be denied bail wouldn't couldn't
be let back on the streets because this
code that he had could be used to
manipulate or crash financial markets if
it was in the wrong hands and I thought
Goldman's the right hands and under
I couldn't believe I was breathtaking I
thought could have been in worse hands
already but a presumably that they would
end it and that this stuff had to do
with high-frequency trading which at
that time no one had ever heard of it
was a term of art that got get all of a
sudden was in the newspapers without
much explanation was just computerized
trading so I took me a couple of years
before I came around to the storage of
the actually doing the story I was doing
other things but when I got into it I
realized I needed a primer on on on high
frequency trading and I just call
friends on Wall Street people who were
investors and said do you know anybody
and they said very weirdly there's this
Canadian guy who's wandering around
you're not going to believe what he will
tell you and yes he knows it he's the
only guy who's not an area 51 guy who
knows about what's going on in with
high-frequency trading so I went to find
Brad Katsuyama but really just for
background for the thing I was the
magazine piece I was doing about Sergey
Elena calls the Russian and a couple of
days into it I realized just with him I
realized that you know the I was very
pleased with doing a magazine piece with
the Russian but there was a book in this
guy's experience and there was a
question about persuading him to do it
and persuading him to let me move into
his life which I did for about a year a
little more than a year that's how it
came about see is it this is a small
point that I'm why wondering whether it
has larger I would notice when I was
reading the book that you return again
and again to the question of with each
of the as Cathy Amma gathers his
confederates around him this is you over
and again returned to the question with
each of these people about how they were
changed by 9/11 you have to really
notice that's true three or four times I
feel like there's that and I'm curious
I'm guessing is that for a very good
reason but so a I'd like to know what
that reason is but more broadly I'm
wondering do you think that the fact
that 9/11 was so much a calamity of the
financial district in some way
alter the generation I mean is it does
it have a kind of does it have a kind of
material effect on the way people people
involved in the markets thought about
what they did is that the point you were
making by bringing it up no it wasn't
the players maybe but I just think that
I did I do think that 9/11 gave Wall
Street cover to behave very badly for a
long stretch because all of we were we
shared an enemy with them and it was and
the depth that was almost a separate
point the point I was making and it's
one of the things I wanted to kind of
get at without actually saying it was
what come to raise the question why do
some people in this environment decide
to behave well why does someone who sees
what's going on in the market a lot of
people know knew that the stock market
was rigged why why this Canadian guy and
this group of people he brings together
why does it bother them more than
everybody else and I think there I think
there the answer is more complicated
than a few of them had traumatic
experiences during 9/11 but all of them
did have this tendency to have a long
view of perspective on their lives from
from maybe becoming live trying to live
their lives the way they wanted to look
back on it rather than living their
lives looking forward to the next bonus
so they weren't as narrowly motivated by
the money as others and in a couple of
cases I think 9/11 really had a lot to
do with that
so that and that's why I kept coming
back to that the the most specific the
most persons most blunt about it is a
great he's only in the book for a little
bit but there's a kid who works for Brad
Council yeah my name's Josh Blackburn
and he he was a freshman in college when
the when it when 9/11 happened on 9/11
they walked out of college and over the
Air Force recruitment center wouldn't
take him for a year he ends up anyway
devoting his life helping generals map
the battlefields in Afghanistan and Iraq
and when he comes back
after nine oh seven or eight years he's
traumatized because he can't find
anything in the economy and for anything
any job for his skill set that he feels
purposeful he's a computer days of
technologists he got job offers from all
the high-frequency trading firms he's
perfect for them he goes in and he finds
it completely Hollow me like he doesn't
actually want to get out of bed in the
morning until he bumps into grad
Katsuyama
who gives him the stealing of purpose
again and they all had this need for a
sense of purpose that was greater than
just how well they were doing that day
and so I wanted the reader to have some
clues about why they why they might be
that way why they were different because
this is the question I mean it's why
them you know it's really it's odd that
that the messenger in this case is odd
this Canadian guy who really is not in
the center of things in the beginning
decides that the world needs to know
some truth that's going on and ends up I
mean this is the role he's going to play
in life he is essentially has walked
into a place with a vacuum of trust and
he becomes a source of trust and
everybody trusted and the power of that
is incredible but why why him and so
that's the that were those were those
were ways to prod the reader into
thinking along those lines do you has
your own feeling about over the course
of so you've returned to well we started
off writing about Wall Street and now
you've returned to it twice
unless you include boomerang and it's
three to three times that's not really
Wall Street have your feelings about
Wall Street and financial markets
evolved over that time are you more
outraged today than you were at the time
of virus poker yes
what what's changed what look like
comedies become tragedy when I when I
was leaving Salomon Brothers I was a
very mixed feelings about the whole
thing I didn't think I was I thought it
was silly would
bothered me then was I've seen just too
many young people who really had some
other purpose in their lives be diverted
into work that wasn't terribly
meaningful best because of the money and
I thought that was dumb and I thought
that I could write a book then and they
would show people what it was and that
they would be they would deem apologize
it instead of course what I did it was
create an advertisement for Wall Street
I mean I can't I mean I thought I did
think I mean it is amazing you never
know what book you've written until
people read it but you know six months
after Lars poker I had a thousand
letters from students at Ohio State
University that said dear mr. Lewis
I read your read your instruction and
you know how to get ahead on Wall Street
and and I just want to make sure there
were no tips you left out because I
really wanted to work on Wall Street but
I so there was enough ambivalence and I
I didn't feel I didn't feel I was on
some I wasn't I wasn't writing from a
moral it wasn't a moral high-ground
exactly it was just a distance I had
attachment I had from him what changed
my mind was the financial crisis I mean
I would particularly started to change
my mind was when all these places all
these big banks committed suicide I mean
when they all they all made all these
these horrible bets and they all should
have all should have failed almost all
of them should have failed and I thought
because up to that point I thought I
thought elinoz I thought they did it
they were exposed to market forces more
than they actually were and so they fail
they were fail but I also thought how
peculiar was that these institutions
that suck in the best and the brightest
again anybody they want almost and these
people who they suck and are not
unselfie interested people that these
are very ambitious
you know people that when all when when
brought together they committed a they
were a failure in the way they were
brought together I thought that was
interesting but I but I also saw that
things that seemed absurd and comic in
1987 or not
a same disastrous now how much more
complex the whole system I guess and
nobody could actually see what was going
on inside of it the consequences for the
larger economy all that and the kind of
steady draining of the soul of the place
come much more corporate much slicker so
I just I become yes less feeling less
warm and fuzzy about it yeah and the
stories and look a lot of times you're
just sort of at the mercy of the story
that walks in the door in this story
this particular story is so much more
black and white most the stories I had
to deal with I mean it isn't a question
of who's right and who's wrong if not
and there's not a lot of middle ground
you have you have it's about a young man
figure out how the stock market works
and he shows you how its rigged he shows
you that shows you the predatory
activity that's going on the evidence is
incontrovertible and it shouldn't be
going on and that and that he is
attacked for delivering the truth I know
so I just see it just seemed that the
interesting thing about the story wasn't
is this right you could you could read
liars poker and you could obviously say
I admire this sort of economic activity
I don't admire the story you get was a
choice I don't need to read this and say
I admire this sort of economic activity
have you been I want to make sure one
more request one more time for one more
yep I have to go to Q&A so we have to
put a Q&A short but before we do one
last bit on this the the reaction to
this book has been extraordinary
we prepared just what you expected would
happen I did think it was an explosive
story I didn't I don't think I could
have ever imagined it would be as
explosive as it has been and it's played
out of theater on TV in the most
extraordinary way I didn't so
I didn't know exactly what to expect
here's a head going against it it has
going against and this is complicated
and the main character is a nice
Canadian I mean no offense but but
nobody remember this at the New Republic
they used to have a headline a boring
headline competition and every week
readers would submit the most boring
headline they could find the newspapers
and there'd be a winner every week we'd
print it at the end of the year we went
out put all of them in a bucket and said
which is the most boring of the most
boring and the winner was worthwhile
Canadian initiative remember remember
what came in second I don't remember
care second second was University of
Rochester decides not to change name so
so I can't believe we so I just didn't
well yeah yeah so I've written a book
it's a word about a worthwhile Canadian
initiative and so so I had that I had
that going against me I I feel like I
deserve some credit yes for just for
taking a worthwhile Canadian initiative
and putting it in the middle of my
narrative and I'm not getting that
credit yet but I will eventually what I
had going for me is that there is a war
waiting to happen and it's a war about
the over the role of the financial
sector in our lives and they've been
just so there's one moment that
crystallized this whole what this the
war for me and it was I was sitting
there I was on TV but I was just
watching it CNBC she decided the first
day the book came out the stage of the
bank wasn't really a debate but it was
people there's people shouting each
other but the I was in one room you know
in a midtown Manhattan and Brad Kathy
Amma is on the New York Stock Exchange
sitting beside the head of a one of the
exchanges that's been rigged by
high-frequency traders its own behalf
was created by high-frequency traders
and owned by middlemen and as the head
of the bats exchange and this guy
proceeded to make an ass of himself I
mean he was he was he
was crazy person screaming and yelling
and he was very odd but the it was a
story I heard after that told me that
why you know why this thing is so
explosive
apparently the trading floor a lot of
trading floors on Wall Street just
stopped when this was there trading the
New York Stock Exchange just stopped
when this is going on it's now the most
watched show in CNBC history which is I
mean it's the tallest [ __ ] but
nevertheless the is something right and
the other I try to get the word [ __ ]
in every one of my books because because
of the first one I use it I got all
these letters who people were offended I
use the word [ __ ] I've got my back up
against the wall aback but let's the
Woodmoor world it was a [ __ ] in that
book but but the the one of these
trading floors it was a goldman sachs
trading floor they're all watching and
the guy tells me story says we're
watching the guy next to me cold goldman
sachs guy says says the the angry guy is
it is it true we own a piece of his
exchange and yeah he goes the little guy
because we don't own a piece of his
exchange no we don't exchange it goes
we're [ __ ]
and so
[Applause]
Wall Street has Wall Street realized the
smart people realize they're [ __ ]
they're on the wrong side of the
argument and and it's coming and it's
going to change so so but what does that
mean that means sucking I mean in the
just a narrow sector of the stock market
billions of dollars a year out of Wall
Street but this model for how a
computerized financial market works has
been grafted onto the Treasury market if
foreign shady market and foreign stock
markets that if a fair market becomes
the model Wall Street screwed that it's
all it only works if is unfairness it
vent a lot of Wall Street just vanishes
so you've got of at stake a huge sums of
money and the sense they're screwed and
once you get that you get a different
sort of reaction from Wall Street's and
then you get from my previous books and
this is what it feels like in retrospect
not at the time but in retrospect what I
have been doing is kind of blindly
whacking away at a great beast with a
baseball bat and why our cover was the
first whack and it didn't really bother
the beast very much I hid it someplace
where it's nerves were not very
sensitive though big short was a second
wife again didn't really do very much
this time I whacked it in the balls
and and it's and it just where the Beast
woke up and because I hit it where the
money's made I mean the money is going
to be taken away and they know it's
going to be taken away and that just
erupted and it erupted into every which
way
financial journalists a part of the
eruption anybody who's got a stake in
the revenues is disturbed so that's that
explains a reaction yeah yeah well thank
you Mike
me
we have time for very much now so now we
go into the Q&A part of the evening is
the quick reminder questions generally
start with a w or an H and sometimes at
thee
they are short we do not believe in
two-part questions and only Malcolm gets
to ask follow-up questions but my first
question Kristen I haven't read the book
that's not a 60 minute ease who are
these bad guys with these high-speed
rated trunk lines I'm sorry who are
these bad people
Chloe's billions of dollars I didn't see
that in the piece the so I'm not going
to name names and I tell you why because
the prop the problem is unsatisfying as
it sounds is the entire system the point
of take where the scalp happens right
now in the market is it a high frequency
trader is scalping you in the market and
they and that's the the intake for the
month the revenues for this system of a
lot of unnecessary financial
intermediation but the revenues are
shared with the exchanges who rigged the
exchange for the high-frequency traders
and the banks and the online brokers who
sell essentially one way or another the
customer stock market orders to the
high-frequency traders to trade against
so identifying single villains is nuts
the minute some reputational risk I kept
a names out on the other side that the
villain is not named not a one because
I've now had to I know what would have
happened what would have happened is
someone would have gotten lynched at the
best case and the problem is if you go
and Lynch one or two of these one or two
high-frequency traders you're not
attacking the system the problem is the
guy is up against the system so if you
google high-frequency trading if you
wonder if you really wanted to know who
the people are who are the best at
scalping you in the market but that's
not you know it arguably they're not the
villains arguably their exchanges their
loans because they've created this
environment where they can do it to you
or the banks to the brokers in the
villains because they've sold your
information out to them but if you
really want to know who the bad
are all you what you really didn't know
who are the high frequency trading firms
they care the most about - there are
high frequency trading firms that don't
care all that much about speed and there
- stray firms that care a lot about
speed the more they care about speed the
more they're involved in the bad
activity and you can you can google and
get the answer
next question michael mattos thank you
so much for being here with the big set
of both of you Michael I know you've
been very critical some of the Goliath
of the financial services industry who
would you say are big david in the
finance research and also what would
people like us do or what should we do
is the stock market is rigged the
wattage is rigged to say for our futures
to pay for retirements that are thank
you so the the book is about David in
the financial system and it's this
Exchange stock-exchange called IX they
built this fit they built an exchange
that's owned by investors the whole
point of is a creation of our
environment where investment investors
are not exposed to the predator who else
is the David's they're the first death
David because they've actually created a
kind of solution to a problem and if it
works which you've got in a model for
how you solve all the problems through
disruptive entrepreneurship and bringing
market forces to bear in a particular
market your own money is a different
question it's interesting because when I
say it's rigged it means there's a
systemic scalp that goes on every time
every time a market an order enters the
market its appendage pennies it's tiny
sum of money spread out over the whole
market it adds up to huge sums of money
so it's not that you're never going to
make money in the stock market that's
not the point the point is that the
market is the market is charging it
sound a way to tax you and all
investment dollars totally unnecessarily
and it's a problem more of a system-wide
problem it is a problem for your
individual savings the free as an
investor you almost should be more
concerned about the instability caused
by the rigging that it's not the pennies
you lose every time you trade in the
stock market it's that this whole you
know
as the guy that Goldman Sachs say when
they decide they don't want anymore what
to do with high-frequency trading in the
current stock market structure there's
going to be a calamity if we don't if we
if we continue down this path of
exchanges making this book system ever
more complicated for the benefit of the
high-frequency traders what can you do
the simple answer is go on a website
that I ax has created called I am an
investor org and explains how you can
take control of your own stock market
orders and create pressure on the banks
and the brokers not to sell you out it's
already happening I mean it's actually
it is a political movement going on in
finance right now in the last week
Charles Schwab has come out and said
that this is a cancer on the industry
that needs to be stopped an online
brokerage firm called Interactive
Brokers has said they're going to now
allow their customers to send their
orders directly into ie X that if you if
the orders are moved on to fair
exchanges and I've no doubt that
competition from what will arise for IX
but whatever the fair exchange is that
you you starve the predator you starve
the beast so that's what you do you try
to put pressure on wherever your
whatever stock market investments you
have you try to try to direct them away
from the system mr. Lewis my question is
about front-running
I live in aware that there were such a
multitude of exchanges and programming
is reliant upon the subsequent wealth
exchanges after bad so my question is
Brad Katsuyama solution is to create an
exchange which disallows funding to
happen by slowing the process down when
does simple solution be just to have a
single exchange so that it's across this
couldn't take place at all absolutely
there's no question about that and the
problem that is the regulator's believe
that competition is necessary for the
exchanges to stay to be to be efficient
and so in the name of competition
they've encouraged this proliferation
the fragmentation actually doesn't
benefit the investor so yes the sensible
solution is for the stock exchange to be
a kind of utility and that we all meet
in one place and that it could happen I
mean it could happen I mean one pass
this whole episode may take the New York
Stock Exchange has been trying for
several months to buy ix and they've ixs
they've already turned them they all
could have been rich already they just
they turned it down because they can't
allow themselves to be sold to the New
York Stock Exchange unless the New York
Stock Exchange gets rid of all the bad
stuff that's going on otherwise it's not
credible but if the New York section
caves and says we will not only will buy
you but will get rid of all the
high-frequency traders who are in them
in the place no more no longer giving
them preferential access you'll be the
New York Stock Exchange it's easy to
imagine exchanges folding everything all
the businesses going on in New York
Stock Exchange you can kind of go back
to the way the market was structured
ages ago but but without human beings in
the middle of it
so with that without the investment
orders passing through hands at all it
just buyers and sellers just meeting so
that is I that is the natural solution
so I think you kind of just press on
this a little bit you know before you
decide to come up here but my question
was going to be IX since I guess up
until now how successful having been at
doing what they're trying to do and I
know there's other exchanges like I had
which is just that whole house is that's
why they've been so far well if you talk
to investors whose orders are being
directed on the exchange extremely that
all of a sudden and the problem you know
Evan manifests itself to investors is
that they think there's a market there
thinks that in these 13 stock markets
say there that there's 10,000 shares bid
for Microsoft at $20 a share and then
they've got to do it in the market
somehow i anticipates what they want to
do in vanishes and goes up and it
doesn't happen when they go on to IX so
they've been very successful in Manoa
it's the measure of how successfully
they're eliminating the predatory
activity is that basically
high-frequency traders don't want to be
connected but the size of the exchange
is still small I mean they're good
they're incredibly successful for a new
exchange starting a new stock exchange
always takes time they're trading
yesterday traded 65 million shares it's
a fraction of the stock market they it's
enough so that they're profitable are
just about profitable and sustainable
but there's a break and the break right
now is that 70% of the stock market
orders in this country are handled by
eight banks only one of those banks is
actually treating the exchange this
exchange honestly the other seven are
doing what they can to avoid sending
their orders onto the exchange and so
pressure has to be brought to bear on
those banks to start moving orders on an
exchange when their customers ask them
to the one is schooling the one is
Goldman yeah other the other seven are
behaving uniformly badly there are
different degrees of badness
but but it means that combined with the
fact that none until interactive brokers
do this none of this online
brokerage firms are sending their orders
on there either they're starved of this
restorative activity a bit but it's
changing you can see I mean this is the
books been out eight days there's
enormous pressure in the system to for
people to if the investors ask for their
orders we directed this way for them to
be directed this way so I it's it's a
pretty hopeful looking situation right
now hi thanks for being here so I'd like
your opinion about what I've looked at
because the 50,000 foot view and that is
when you have guys like Hank Paulson who
used to run Goldman and then was running
the Treasury Department and other former
bank guys and government positions it's
sort of like on the Foxes of chicken
coop regardless of all the things that
are going on with high-frequency traders
if the problems spend at the top and
that is the guidelines of going to jail
is some some schmuck for seven years and
the big guys like Lloyd plankton or
other Goldman execs who are purposely
setting against their clients and
nobody's going to do anything about it
because when these Fed guys were
finished at the Johnson line different
wood they weren't important for the
bank's what's to be done you know it's
amazing is that if you to ask me that
sort of question say when liars poker
came out I thought you're in that case I
mean I really I saw and that's kinda the
conspiracy guy it's absolutely true what
you said
and not only you didn't just say it two
days ago a prosecutor from the FEC who
was just retiring stood up in front of
the FCC and got up late to applause and
said the problem with this institution
is every one of you want to go get a
higher paying job on Wall Street and
you're afraid to do anything but address
very small street-level crime you want
to be nothing but polite to the people
who are running the institution we have
no ability to regulate it because we're
corrupted by the money I mean and they
all said yes
and so it's uh it's a problem right so
how do you solve this problem I mean
we're kind of you can you can you fit
Brad katsuyama when he first discovers
himself being front-run very cleverly
and is able to demonstrate it because
he's Canadian
instead of making a steak he's the size
I had to go tell the US government
because it would be rude to go and make
a steak without telling the SEC what's
going on because they probably want to
do something about it right and so he
goes to the FCC and describes this to
him and he leaves six in after the
conversation where in which SEC people
say oh what's the problem of that it
makes me nothing's going to happen he
thinks they're never going to do
anything and he goes back to his
Canadian bank and they start talking
about why would they be that way and
they do a little study and they find out
then the previous three years more than
200 people have left the SEC to go to
work for high-frequency traders are
lobbying firms that lobby five free
traders they say maybe that's why they
do that but so what do you do do you
despair because the whole system seems
to be riddled and the industry this
problem in the marketplace in this
particular market is a microcosm of the
larger problem the larger problem is the
industries generate generates so much
money how that it's it's captured not
just the regulatory process to the
legislative process and so you could
there's no it's I think futile to look
to Washington for a solution to the
problem however we live in a country
where people worship entrepreneurship
love market-based solutions so what's so
clever about what this guy has done is
he has created a solution that does not
require really much in the way of
anything from Washington all they got to
do is stay out of the way we sail away
and let him provoke the war between
investors between the between capital
and the people who are abusing the
capital
and AIESEC he'll win and I think he
thinks he's going to win so it this is
maybe the way forward and if you do this
if he succeeds I think so much is at
stake if he succeeds and he has a huge
successful Stock Exchange and he's
gotten rich and all the people who work
for him or all whom are young and
entrepreneurial what happens next
venture capital pours in to do it again
and again and again in different sectors
of Wall Street and then all you require
really at that point is for the
regulators or legislators not to get in
the way of successful entrepreneurship
and possibly introduce some more
transparency to the marketplace so
customers can make informed decisions
about what they do it and it's fixed I
mean I think is that there's a path
towards a market-based solutions he has
opened up which is you know that's so
that's what's at stake here I think
because precisely what you said is true
the government's cashing if only if the
SEC permitted the the growth of many
competing exchanges because itself that
competition among exchanges was good why
didn't they also at the same time allow
investors to choose which exchange they
wanted it's a really good question the
truth is there is a rule that does allow
investors to insist if some SEC will to
fin rule which is another governing body
that allows investors to have to insist
on where their orders go it's being
broken so the law the rules are being
broken I don't know whether what kind of
violation it is you will read about this
at some point in the newspaper in the
next month or two there's news stories
waiting to be written so the rules are
actually in place investors don't aren't
exercising their rights they've left no
no history of it they've never asked
where the order goes they don't very
hard for them to find out where it goes
and how it's directed so it's a problem
it's more of a problem of the just
historically has never been done and now
it's now it was a radical it was a
radical acrobats
I'm going to go to fidelity or go to
tiro price and say start telling them
where to send your orders because they
never done it before and the bank's got
cute were furious that he was telling
them to do that but that's what he's
done and they're they're doing it so
it's a now it's a matter of the rules
being enforced more than anything else
in our final question all right last one
so after what you just said I can see
why you have some optimism that this
could get turned around because because
the individual does have some power but
so therefore how would you rank this
against something like the weeb or
scandal or the municipal bond review and
you know scams that like JP Morgan does
to like places like Alabama and stuff
where they get no big contract so here's
what I think so here's here's the this
is clearly the other thing about this
story it is of a piece with the the
spirit of the age in the financial
markets everywhere you look markets are
getting rigged the LIBOR scandal is
about rigging interest rate Marxist the
foreign exchange of the foreign exchange
rigging scandal their commodities price
rigging scandals why are markets all of
a sudden so communities so heavily
manipulated by big Wall Street banks
well it's the well it's polish because
they can but partly it's because the
historic so a lot of the historic
sources of revenue for Wall Street have
dried up I mean it and style has been
cramped by dodd-frank and so part of it
is a response to it's a survival
instinct I think in banks and the
individual traders in the banks and this
is the rigging of the scholars that say
it's it's it's the same thing playing
out the stock market so I think that and
I think that's why it's happening I
think it's because basically technology
has reduced the the natural role the
useful role played by Wall Street
historically it eliminated it in some
markets and they've got to find other
things to do and one of the things you
do is you rig markets
on that note thank you very much thank
you don't you give them a round of
applause thank you so the bookstore's
has some free signed books for those who
don't want to stick around for those are
you going to have your book signed we're
going to bring you up biro we're just
going to bring a table out here just
give us a couple of minutes to get
organized thank you for coming if you
have any questions visit our website
live talks la org Barnes & Noble is out
on the patio they have some pre signed
Malcolm Gladwell books available for
sale only Michael Lewis will be signing
books up here though thank you
thank you
you